l'explication n'est pas de base à l'est
en 15 secondes ya deux équipes les
gardiens qui combattent au sonar mûri et
qui donc son armée le prisonnier qui
commence dans une cellule et qui donc
n'ont pas d'armes à part un couteau mais
quelquefois ils peuvent trouver un
pistolet dans leurs toilettes et ne
demandez pas pourquoi j'en sais rien les
prisonniers doivent faire ce que les
gardiens nordistes sous peine d'être
tués ils n'ont pas droit aux arbres donc
c'est un gardien volant prisonniers avec
une arme dans la main bay le but est
l'objectif des prisonniers de tuer le
gardien où les gardiens si on a
plusieurs cordes allemand la direction
mais tout le monde n'est plus en phase
là bas tu vas dans la cellule
ouais ok donc des jeunes incapables eu
aller dans la cellule
mais qu'est ce que tu fais là monde à
celle du milieu où je vous jure c'est un
s'installe un stade hay de la cie ce
matin
ok dans la cellule hugo vas-y j'ai pas
l'autorité ça m'énerve
le fou et qui met un coup de couteau
dont un peu à part dans ce que c'est je
défonce à michael me taper au signal au
vote
venez viens viens ici tous les boutons
et tu rentres là dedans
le chef vous stresser le père du couple
est parti ce point de mal mais on peut
pas voir ta gueule oui ça va bien le
temps ça va bien
et je vous la peur de voir si tout va
bien on arrête ses toiles mais cette
aventure t'es mort ac 1 2 dans un stade
louis ii dans allés chacun lit pas
dessus rallye bordel
ok offert 2 3 soleil qu'est rien 2 3
soleil aujourd'hui la cfa 2 3 soleil 1 2
3 soleil 1 2 3 soleil non tu vas pas y
arriver
4 le oui allait autant pas tout à fait
alors si tu prends larmes du témoin mais
pourquoi j'ai pas faire ça à hugo la
free center savourer mon vol ce truc de
l'intérieur [ __ ] de merde et ben
jassem et jeanne bord ok je sais pas ce
que c'est oui la [ __ ] ou passé huit
mois
wen a dit colette boîte il est où c'est
parti allez hop eagle eye est jeune on
regarde bien tchakarian top on vous
regarde et vous regardez le mur allait
content car je reviens je vois assez bon
ouais ok maintenant vous me regardez on
va jouer
on va à jacques a dit ok ok la bonne
phrase c'est jacques a dit hadi l'acadia
couple et l'autre qui au dessus qui
alarme inea comme ça il doit bloquer son
blizzard vers le bas ne plus bouger
sauter et urée ok donc magie commence à
jeûner s'ils allaient aussi à j'ai fait
un truc de dingue arrive je cherchais
pas à temps est ce que est ce que j'ai
le droit d'aller quelque part c'est plus
égaux donc tu cherchais le deuxième où
il est il est dans la cellule l'aj
auxerre est allé dans les allemands je
vais déroulé un chargeur opérateurs non
non non on regarde
[Musique]
ok j'ai perdu et roger y avait une
musique épique et tout dans ma tête mais
pas du tout le produit il est là donc si
tu vas tu crèves ok ok tu es celui qui
était rien faire pour revenir sinon je
t'aime une balle c'était la roue
millions dans spartacus qui en apportent
non non non non non mais t'es toi aller
trop l'ambiance je venais tout le monde
dans la cellule d'isolation elle voit
entrer la main des passes ta moan et
parce que je lui tire dessus
pardon attention aux de faire attention
aya vous sortez tous ces mamans c'est sa
rencontre ici c'est mika ou tarte un
certain c'est un ou deux qui se
dénoncent tout de suite c'est pas moche
jacadi accroupi l'association et je veux
vous voir tous les trois ans devant moi
en ligne ici le oui à la longue voilà
ici tous les trois en ligne quelqu'un
manque à l'appel
mais carnin chemy thatcher je veux que
vous dansiez je fais les stroboscopes
fait mal
[Musique]
je veux tout le monde dans la cnae faria
hockey à ces partis j'affronte quelqu'un
dans l'arène voilà c'est parti
voilà tu te cacher à droite donc non
c'est moi c'est moi qui bouge et c'est
moi je te chercher à droite
tarte à la citrouille jeunes là et
appuie maintenant tu vas sur un des
quatre qui vous choisit up vas-y me suis
rendu 4 ok musée à toi choisi un des
quatre années à ouvrir il est au fait
comment pour des 115 tu vas tu me dis
qu'en samoa pas me piquer piqué à l'ailé
c'est la famille k way j'ai connu cette
année ça va marcher
erika et lâchez vos armes que vous ne
verrez ça seras gentil des parts un
lâche son arme j'ai pas d'armes [ __ ]
mais je n'avais pas résoudre et dès que
j'arrête la musique le dernier qui
s'arrêtent de danser et qui a perdu il
se prend une balle
[Musique]
à la roulette là comme tout à l'heure il
est allé non pas là la basse elle vous
savez pas sur quoi vous allez tomber à
fait d'accord le bloc là bas allez hop 1
aller 2 2 ok attendu à tanger à tétouan
et mal à vous avancez j'attends qu'ils
avancent et oui 3 jacques a dit hadi
accroupi la pression qui vous bécaud
jacadi sauter ces jaquettes tin tin tin
tu souhaites tu fais un 3/6 c'est parti
joli retour à 3 720 quoi attends tu
donnes trois costauds pour avoir à 700
années tu vas travailler plus tôt ok
d'accord
attendez je change cela lui coûtera
secondes
direction le le plongeoir à l'aller
toujours d'accord mais bon et la tartine
pour acheter quoi ces aléas des
poubelles tape un effet la discothèque
allez vous sauter tous les deux en même
temps à 2,3 sauté aux yeux
les tartares de croisset quant à la
volonté je vais faire une rouler une
roulette chinois c'était quand on saute
à stoneham
mais d'accord ni café début de phrase et
je fais la fin cia et vous devez faire
le truc que s'il ya deux fois a dit tu
vois jacadi accroupissez vous voilà
maintenant acadienne sauter voilà
jacques a dit hadi a confié jacques
abadie a dit debout à nouveau les restes
un groupe bien j'ai le droit de parler
jacques à debbie allen ou utilisation
j'ai gagné a dit sauter bah oui fazila
pas cela parce qu'ils croient trop à
chaque fois c'est génial ça c'est
vraiment la place pour faire une deux au
fait une deux parties mika tapas à
hampden 2 super mario lemieux en fait
partie de la n3 à l'uqar au quai de la
fosse aux mâts et couilles tu t'étais
abandon mais si je défais un dribble
unique
je répète nous donnez moi je sais très
bien qu'il a trouvé des bus faisait plus
de quatre secondes par contre je sais
pas du tout pourquoi j'ai tenu ce l'on
attend pour vous dire en tout cas c'est
à bruxelles
[Musique]
et